With the billions of dollars being spent on
blockbuster films, it's hard to watch an epic
action, fantasy, or science fiction movie
just once. But even with repeat viewings,
some awesome or unbelievable details always
seem to slip by viewers' eyes. We're determined
to fill fans in on every cool easter egg or
inside reference, so we hope you enjoy Screen
Rant's 10 Amazing Hidden Details in Movies.
Pearl Harbor(Buena Vista)
Plenty of cash was spent on the special effects
of Pearl Harbor, but apparently, either director
Michael Bay or the special effects team decided
they still had room for some fun. Once the
movie made it to home video, fans started
noticing a standout extra among the wounded
sailors. As strange as it may seem, it appears
that Bruce Willis' tough-as-nails cop John
McClane has been spliced out of Die Hard,
and into the WWII-era drama. Since the footage
of a bruised, battered McClane in an undershirt
isn't an exact match to any Die Hard scene,
some skeptics say it's all coincidence. But
the size and perspective shows it's clearly
an added digital effect, and one that can
never be missed once it's pointed out.
The Matrix(Warner Bros.)
Most fans of The Wachowski's game-changing
sci-fi series know that the movie's plot forms
a perfect circle: the hotel and room 303 where
the movie begins is also the same place where
Neo becomes "The One". But fans probably missed
an even bigger example. The first movie ended
with a serious phone call, as Neo told the
Machines that he planned on freeing humanity.
Two sequels followed, but when Neo finally
ended the war in his epic battle with Agent
Smith, their fight is set at that exact intersection.
When the two slam into the street, you can
even catch a glimpse of the phonebooth from
the first film. Talk coming full circle.
Iron Man(Marvel/Disney)
Tony Stark found out the hard way that even
friends can't be trusted, when his business
partner Obadiah Stane revealed he was funding
terrorists. But Iron Man should have known
he was up to no good long before. When Tony
finds Stane playing some piano in his Malibu
mansion, it's not a random bit of music, but
a sample of Antonio Salieri's Piano Concerto
in C.
Music buffs, or those who saw the movie Amadeus
will get the hint, since Salieri was long
rumored to have sabotaged and killed Mozart.
The composers' rivalry wasn't anywhere close
to Stark and Stane's but the hint was there
all along.
The LEGO Movie(Warner Bros.)
Directors Chris Miller and Phil Lord beat
the odds when they made a movie about LEGO
a worldwide hit. The film even included Superman
and Green Lantern, played by Channing Tatum
and Jonah Hill, the stars of their previous
surprise hit, the rebooted 21 Jump Street.
It wasn't the only nod to the story of undercover
cops, though. When Emmet's apartment is first
shown, a poster can be seen advertising the
movie "Teen Copz," an obvious reference to
Jump Street. But the poster next to it takes
the cake, since the Tatum/Hill comedy really
was sold to Russian audiences as "Macho and
the Nerd".
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire(Warner
Bros.)
For those not versed in Harry Potter mythology,
we'll just say that to bring down Lord Voldemort,
the three Deathly Hallows were sort of an
important combination. It wasn't until the
second last book that audiences learned that
a cloak, stone, and Elder Wand held the key
to victory, but the idea was teased ahead
of time. As in, two full movies ahead of time.
In one of the franchise's best easter eggs,
Dumbledore tells Harry that he's been searching
for such a detail. The answer is literally
right in front of him, in the form of a 3d
version of the Deathly Hallows symbols stored
in his own office.
Mission: Impossible - Ghost Protocol(Paramount
Pictures)
Every fan of Disney and Pixar knows to keep
an eye out for the code "A113," the room number
that the studio's top animators all studied
in when attending the California Institute
of the Arts. But it doesn't stop at animated
movies. When Brad Bird graduated from directing
movies like The Incredibles and Ratatouille
to Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol, he made
sure to give a nod to his roots. Watch closely,
and you'll spot the code on a trick ring used
by IMF agents to inject a sleeping agent into
their unsuspecting target.
The Hunger Games: Catching Fire(Lionsgate)
The Hunger Games series took a major step
up in budget and spectacle with its second
installment, but not every addition was taken
completely seriously. When Katniss and Peeta
are heading out to make their grand entrance
before the next Games, the doorway they pass
under is clearly marked with the code PDL-736.
The meaning isn't complicated, it's just an
address: 736 Ponce de Leon Avenue, a hip hop
nightclub that the cast would frequent when
filming in Atlanta, Georgia.
Man of Steel(Warner Bros.)
Zack Snyder and Warner Bros. wanted to make
a clean start with Man of Steel, but that
didn't mean the director wanted to ignore
the version of the DC hero who came before,
specifically, the original films from director
Richard Donner. The updated version of the
ship that brought Kal-El to Earth played a
big part in the story, but when Kal-El had
his escape explained by his father Jor-El,
the version of the ship is obviously modelled
after Donner's version, not Snyder's.
The Avengers Age of Ultron(Marvel/Disney)
It wasn't just powerful fighters or alien
invaders that Marvel's Avengers had to tackle
in their second team-up, but a girl who could
force them to face their worst fears, or tempt
them with a better life. For Captain America,
that meant sending him back to a USO soiree
before he was frozen for decades. Pay attention
to the band though: the Roy Thomas Players
aren't named after a musician, but a Marvel
Comics legend. Roy Thomas spent years writing
X-Men, Avengers, Doctor Strange, and even
created modern characters like Adam Warlock,
and Vision, who makes his movie debut in the
same film.
Star Trek Into Darkness(Paramount)
Before Chris Hemsworth was famous as the Marvel
hero Thor, he splashed onto the scene playing
Captain Kirk's father George. The 2009 reboot
saw George killed in battle aboard the USS
Kelvin, but his legacy, and that of the ship,
lived on. In the sequel, fans were probably
too busy trying to make sense of the bomb
plot and blood transfusions to notice that
the scene of the disaster was the Kelvin Memorial
Archive. Named for Kirk's ship, it means the
destruction of the Kelvin set the plots of
both films in motion - a subtle nod that only
the diehard fans might have caught.
We want to hear from you if we missed any
of your favorite easter eggs, obscure references
or hidden secrets in our comments section.
If you liked this video make sure you click
on subscribe to get other great content and
check out our other videos! You won’t be
disappointed! Thanks!